The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So welcome back.
We're going to finish this
chapter on maximum likelihood
estimation.
And last time, I briefly
mentioned something that
was called Fisher information.
So Fisher information,
in general,
is actually a matrix when you
have a multivariate parameter
theta.
So if theta, for example,
is of dimension d,
then the Fisher
information matrix
is going to be a d by d matrix.
You can see that, because
it's the outer product.
So it's of the form
gradient gradient transpose.
So if it's gradient
gradient transpose,
the gradient is
the d dimensional.
And so gradient times gradient
transpose is a d by d matrix.
And so this matrix
actually contains--
well, tells you it's called
Fisher information matrix.
So it's basically
telling you how much
information about the
theta is in your model.
So for example, if your model
is very well-parameterized,
then you will have a
lot of information.
You will have a higher--
so let's think of it as
being a scalar number,
just one number
now-- so you're going
to have a larger information
about your parameter
in the same probability
distribution.
But if start having a weird
way to parameterize your model,
then the Fisher information
is actually going to drop.
So as a concrete example
think of, for example,
a parameter of interest
in a Gaussian model,
where the mean is
known to be zero.
But what you're interested in
is the variance, sigma squared.
If I'm interested
in sigma square,
I could parameterize my model
by sigma, sigma squared, sigma
to the fourth, sigma to 24th.
I could parameterize
it by whatever I want,
then I would have a
simple transformation.
Then you could say
that some of them
are actually more
or less informative,
and you're going to
have different values
for your Fisher information.
So let's just review a few
well-known computations.
So I will focus primarily on the
one dimensional case as usual.
And I claim that
there's two definitions.
So if theta is a real
valued parameter,
then there's basically
two definitions
that you can think of for
your Fisher information.
One involves the
first derivative
of your log likelihood.
And the second one involves
the second derivative.
So the log likelihood
here, we're
actually going to
define it as l of theta.
And what is it?
Well, it's simply the likelihood
function for one observation.
So it's l-- and I'm going to
write 1 just to make sure that
we all know what we're talking
about one observation--
of-- which is the order again,
I think it's X and theta.
So that's the log
likelihood, remember?
So for example, if
I have a density,
what is it going to be?
It's going to be log
of f sub theta of X.
So this guy is a
random variable,
because it's a function
of a random variable.
And that's what you see
expectations of this thing.
It's a random function of theta.
If I view this as a
function of theta,
the function becomes
random, because it
depends on this random X.
And so I of theta is actually
defined as the variance
of l prime of theta--
so the variance of the
derivative of this function.
And I also claim that it's equal
to negative the expectation
of the second
derivative of theta.
And here, the expectation
and the variance
are computed, because this
function, remember, is random.
So I need to tell you
what is the distribution
of the X with
respect to which I'm
computing the expectation
and the variance.
And it's the theta itself.
So typically, the
theta we're going
to be interested in--
so there's a Fisher
information for all
values of the parameter,
but the one typically
we're interested in
is the true
parameter, theta star.
But view this as a function
of theta right now.
So now, I need to prove
to you-- and this is not
a trivial statement-- the
variance of the derivative
is equal to negative
the expectation
of the second derivative.
I mean, there's really quite a
bit that comes into this right.
And it comes from the fact that
this is a log not of anything.
It's the log of a density.
So let's just prove
that without having
to bother too much
ourselves with
some technical assumptions.
And the technical assumptions
are the assumptions
that allow me to permute
derivative and integral.
Because when I compute the
variances and expectations,
I'm actually integrating
against the density.
And what I want to do is to make
sure that I can always do that.
So my technical assumptions
are I can always permute
integral and derivatives.
So let's just prove this.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to assume
that X has density f theta.
And I'm actually just
going to write-- well, let
me write it f theta right now.
Let me try to not be
lazy about writing.
And so the thing
I'm going to use
is the fact that the integral of
this density is equal to what?
1.
And this is where I'm going
to start doing weird things.
That means that if I take
the derivative of this guy,
it's equal to 0.
So that means that if I look
at the derivative with respect
to theta of integral f theta
of X dX, this is equal to 0.
And this is where I'm
actually making this switch,
is that I'm going to say
that this is actually
equal to the integral
of the derivative.
So that's going to be the
first thing I'm going to use.
And of course, if it's true
for the first derivative,
it's going to be true for
the second derivative.
So I'm going to actually
do it a second time.
And the second thing
I'm going to use
is the fact the integral
of the second derivative
is equal to 0.
So let's start from here.
And let me start from,
say, the expectation
of the second derivative
of l prime theta.
So what is l prime prime theta?
Well, it's the second derivative
of log of f theta of X.
And we know that the
derivative of the log--
sorry-- yeah, so the derivative
of the log is 1 over--
well, it's the derivative
of f divided by f itself.
Everybody's with me?
Just log of f prime
is f prime over f.
Here, it's just that f, I view
this as a function of theta
and not as a function of X.
So now, I need to take another
derivative of this thing.
So that's going to be equal to--
well, so we all know the
formula for the derivative
of the ratio.
So I pick up the second
derivative times f theta
minus the first
derivative squared
divided by f theta squared--
basic calculus.
And now, I need to check
that negative the expectation
of this guy is giving
me back what I want.
Well what is negative the
expectation of l prime prime
of theta?
Well, what we need to do
is to do negative integral
of this guy against f theta.
So it's minus the integral of--
That's just the definition
of the expectation.
I take an integral
against f theta.
But here, I have something nice.
What's happening is that
those guys are canceling.
And now that those
guys are canceling,
those guys are canceling too.
So what I have is
that the first term--
I'm going to break
this difference here.
So I'm going to say that
integral of this difference
is the difference
of the integrals.
So the first term is
going to be the integral
of d over d theta
squared of f theta.
And the second one, the negative
signs are going to cancel,
and I'm going to
be left with this.
Everybody's following?
Anybody found the mistake?
How about the other mistake?
I don't know if
there's a mistake.
I'm just trying to get you
to check what I'm doing.
With me so far?
So this guy here is the integral
of the second the derivative
of f of X dX.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: It's 0.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It's 0.
And that's because of this guy,
which I will call frowny face.
So frowny face tells me this.
And let's call this guy
monkey that hides his eyes.
No, let's just do
something simpler.
Let's call it star.
And this guy, we
will use later on.
So now, I have to prove
that this guy, which
I have proved is
equal to this, is now
equal to the variance
of l prime theta.
So now, let's go back
to the other way.
We're going to meet halfway.
I'm going to have a series--
I want to prove that this
guy is equal to this guy.
And I'm going to have
a series of equalities
that I'm going to meet halfway.
So let's start
from the other end.
We started from the negative
l prime prime theta.
Let's start with
the variance part.
Variance of l prime of theta,
so that's the variance--
so that's the
expectation of l prime
of theta squared minus the
square of the expectation of l
prime of theta.
Now, what is the square
of the expectation
of l prime of theta?
Well, l prime of theta is equal
to the partial with respect
to theta of log f theta of X,
which we know from the first
line over there-- that's what's
in the bracket on the second
line there--
is actually equal to the
partial over theta of f
theta X divided by
f theta X. That's
the derivative of the log.
So when I look at the
expectation of this guy,
I'm going to have the integral
of this against f theta.
And the f thetas are
going to cancel again,
just like I did here.
So this thing is actually
equal to the integral
of partial over theta
of f theta of X dX.
And what does this equal to?
0, by the monkey hiding is eyes.
So that's star-- tells me
that this is equal to 0.
So basically, when I compute
the variance, this term is not.
Going to matter.
I only have to
complete the first one.
So what is the first one?
Well, the first one is the
expectation of l prime squared.
And so that guy is the integral
of-- well, what is l prime?
Again, it's partial
over partial theta
f theta of X divided by f theta
of X. Now, this time, this guy
is squared against the density.
So one of the f thetas cancel.
But now, I'm back to what
I had before for this guy.
So this guy is now
equal to this guy.
There's just the same formula.
So they're the same thing.
And so I've moved both ways.
Starting from the
expression that
involves the expectation
of the second derivative,
I've come to this guy.
And starting from the
expression that tells me
about the variance of
the first derivative,
I've come to the same guy.
So that completes my proof.
Are there any questions
about the proof?
We also have on our way found an
explicit formula for the Fisher
information as well.
So now that I have this
thing, I could actually
add that if X has a
density, for example,
this is also equal
to the integral of--
well, the partial over
theta of f theta of X
squared divided by f
theta of X, because I just
proved that those two
things were actually
equal to the same thing,
which was this guy.
Now in practice, this is really
going to be the useful one.
The other two are going
to be useful depending
on what case you're in.
So if I ask you to compute
the Fisher information,
you have now three
ways to pick from.
And basically,
practice will tell you
which one to choose if you
want to save five minutes when
you're doing your computations.
Maybe you're the guy who
likes to take derivatives.
And then you're going to go
with the second derivative one.
Maybe you're the guy who
likes to extend squares,
so you're going to
take the one that
involves the square
of the squared prime.
And maybe you're
just a normal person,
and you want to use that guy.
Why do I care?
This is the Fisher information.
And I could have defined the
[? Hilbert ?] information
by taking the square
root of this guy
plus the sine of this thing
and just be super happy
and have my name in textbooks.
But this thing has a
very particular meaning.
When we're doing the maximum
likelihood estimation--
so remember the maximum
likelihood estimation is just
an empirical version of trying
to minimize the KL divergence.
So what we're trying to
do, maximum likelihood,
is really trying to
minimize the KL divergence.
And we're trying to minimize
this function, remember?
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to plot this function.
We said that, let's
place ourselves
in cases where
this KL is convex,
so that the inverse is concave.
So it's going to
look like this--
U-shaped, that's convex.
So that's the truth thing
I'm trying to minimize.
And what I said is that
I'm going to actually try
to estimate this guy.
So in practice,
I'm going to have
something that looks like
this, but it's not really this.
And we're not going
to do this, but you
can show that you
can control this
uniformly over the entire space,
that there is no space where
it just becomes huge.
In particular, this
is not the space
where it just
becomes super huge,
and the minimum
of the dotted line
becomes really
far from this guy.
So if those two functions
are close to each other,
then this implies that the
minimum here of the dotted line
is close to the minimum
of the solid line.
So we know that
this is theta star.
And this is our MLE,
estimator, theta hat ml.
So that's basically
the principle--
the more data we have,
the closer the dotted line
is to the solid line.
And so the minimum is
closer to the minimum.
But now, this is
just one example,
where I drew a picture for you.
But there could be some
really nasty examples.
Think of this
example, where I have
a function, which is convex,
but it looks more like this.
That's convex, it's U-shaped.
It's just a professional U.
Now, I'm going to put a dotted
line around it that has pretty
much the same fluctuations.
The bend around it
is of this size.
So do we agree that the
distance between the solid line
and the dotted line is
pretty much the same
in those two pictures?
Now, here, depending
on how I tilt this guy,
basically, I can put the minimum
theta star wherever I want.
And let's say that here,
I actually put it here.
That's pretty much the
minimum of this line.
And now, the minimum of the
dotted line is this guy.
So they're very far.
The fact that I'm very
flat at the bottom
makes my requirements
for being close
to the U-shaped solid
curve much more stringent,
if I want to stay close.
And so this is the
canonical case.
This is the annoying case.
And of course, you
have the awesome case--
looks like this.
And then whether
you deviate, you
can have something
that moves pretty far.
It doesn't matter, it's
always going to stay close.
Now, what is the quantity
that measures how
curved I am at a given point--
how curved the function
is at a given point?
The secondary derivative.
And so the Fisher information is
negative the second derivative.
Why the negative?
Well here-- Yeah, we're
looking for a minimum,
and this guy is really
the-- you should view
this as a reverted function.
This is we're trying to
maximize the likelihood, which
is basically maximizing
the negative KL.
So the picture I'm showing you
is trying to minimize the KL.
So the truth picture that
you should see for this guy
is the same, except that
it's just flipped over.
But the curvature is the same,
whether I flip my sheet or not.
So it's the same thing.
So apart from this
negative sign,
which is just
coming from the fact
that we're maximizing
instead of minimizing,
this is just telling me
how curved my likelihood is
around the maximum.
And therefore, it's actually
telling me how good,
how robust my maximum
likelihood estimator is.
It's going to tell me how
close, actually, my likelihood
estimator is going to be--
maximum likelihood is going
to be to the true parameter.
So I should be able
to see that somewhere.
There should be some
statement that tells me
that this Fisher
information will
play a role when assessing the
precision of this estimator.
And remember, how do we
characterize a good estimator?
Well, we look at its bias,
or we look its variance.
And we can combine the two
and form the quadratic risk.
So essentially, what
we're going to try to say
is that one of those
guys-- either the bias
or the variance or
the quadratic risk--
is going to be worse if
my function is flatter,
meaning that my Fisher
information is smaller.
And this is exactly the
point of this last theorem.
So let's look at a
couple of conditions.
So this is your typical
1950s statistics
paper that has like one
page of assumptions.
And this was like that
in the early days,
because people
were trying to make
theories that would be valid
for as many models as possible.
And now, people are
sort of abusing this,
and they're just making all
this lists of assumptions
so that their
particular method works
for their particular
problem, because they just
want to take shortcuts.
But really, the maximum
likelihood estimator
is basically as old
as modern statistics.
And so this was really
necessary conditions.
And we'll just parse that.
The model is identified.
Well, better be, because
I'm trying to estimate
theta and not P theta.
So this one is good.
For all theta, the support of P
theta does not depend on theta.
So that's just something
that we need to have.
Otherwise, things
become really messy.
And in particular,
I'm not going to be
able to define likelihood--
Kullback-Leibler divergences.
Then why can I not do that?
Well, because the
Kullback-Leibler divergence
has a log of the ratio
of two densities.
And if one of the support
is changing with theta
is it might be they have
the log of something that's
0 or something that's not 0.
And the log of 0 is a slightly
annoying quantity to play with.
And so we're just
removing that case.
Nothing depends on theta--
think of it as being
basically the entire real line
as a support for
Gaussian, for example.
Theta star is not on
the boundary of theta.
Can anybody tell me
why this is important?
We're talking about derivatives.
So when I want to talk
about derivatives,
I'm talking about fluctuations
around a certain point.
And if I'm at the boundary,
it's actually really annoying.
I might have the
derivative-- remember,
I give you this example--
where the maximum likelihood is
just obtained at the boundary,
because the function cannot
grow anymore at the boundary.
But it does not mean
that the first order
derivative is equal to 0.
It does not mean anything.
So all this picture
here is valid
only if I'm actually
achieving the minimum inside.
Because if my theta space stops
here and it's just this guy,
I'm going to be here.
And there's no questions
about curvature or anything
that comes into play.
It's completely different.
So here, it's inside.
Again, think of theta as
being the entire real line.
Then everything is inside.
I is invertible.
What does it mean for a
positive number, a 1 by 1 matrix
to be invertible?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: It'd be equal
to its [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: A 1 by 1
matrix, that's a number, right?
What is a characteristic-- if I
give you a matrix with numbers
and ask you if it's
invertible, what
are you going to do with it?
AUDIENCE: Check if
the determinant is 0.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Check
if the determinant is 0.
What is the determinant
of the 1 by 1 matrix?
It's just the number itself.
So that's basically, you want
to check if this number is 0
or not.
So we're going to think in
the one dimensional case here.
And in the one dimensional
case, that just
means that the
curvature is not 0.
Well, it better be not
0, because then I'm
going to have no guarantees.
If I'm totally flat,
if I have no curvature,
I'm basically totally
flat at the bottom.
And then I'm going
to get nasty things.
Now, this is not true.
I could have the curvature
which grows like-- so here, it's
basically-- the second
derivative is telling me--
if I do the Taylor
expansion, it's
telling me how I grow as a
function of, say, x squared.
It's the quadratic term
that I'm controlling.
It could be that this guy is
0, and then the term of order,
x to the fourth, is picking up.
That could be the first
one that's non-zero.
But that would mean that
my rate of convergence
would not be square root of n.
When I'm actually playing
central limit theorem,
it would become n to the 1/4th.
And if I have all a bunch
of 0 until the 16th order,
I would have n to the
1/16th, because that's really
telling me how flat I am.
So we're going to
focus on the case
where it's only quadratic
terms, and the rates
of the central limit
theorems kick in.
And then a few other
technical conditions--
we just used a couple of them.
So I permuted
limit and integral.
And you can check that
really what you want
is that the integral of a
derivative is equal to 0.
Well, it just means that
the values at the two ends
are actually the same.
So those are slightly
different things.
So now, what we have is that
the maximum likelihood estimator
has the following
two properties.
The first one, if I were to
say that in words, what would
I say, that theta hat is--
Is what?
Yeah, that's what I
would say when I--
that's for mathematicians.
But if I'm a statistician,
what am I going to say?
It's consistent.
It's a consistent
estimator of theta star.
It converges in
probability to theta star.
And then we have this sort
of central limit theorem
statement.
The central limit theorem
statement tells me that if this
was an average and I remove the
expectation of the average--
let's say it's 0, for example--
then square root of n
times the average blah
goes through some
normal distribution.
This is telling me that
this is actually true,
even if theta hat has nothing
to do with an average.
That's remarkable.
Theta hat might not
even have a closed form,
and I'm still having
basically the same properties
as an average that
would be given to me
by a central limit theorem.
And what is the
asymptotic variance?
So that's the variance in the n.
So here, I'm thinking of having
those guys being multivariate.
And so I have the inverse
of the covariance matrix
that shows up as the
variance-covariance matrix
asymptotically.
But if you think of just being
a one dimensional parameter,
it's one over this
Fisher information,
one over the curvature.
So the curvature is
really flat, the variance
becomes really big.
If the function is really
flat, curvature is low,
variance is big.
If the curvature is very high,
the variance becomes very low.
And so that
illustrates everything
that's happening with the
pictures that we have.
And if you look,
what's amazing here,
there is no square root 2
pi, there's no fudge factors
going on here.
This is the asymptotic
variance, nothing else.
It's all in there,
all in the curvature.
Are there any
questions about this?
So you can see here that theta
star is the true parameter.
And the information matrix
is evaluated at theta star.
That's the point that matters.
When I drew this
picture, the point
that was at the very bottom
was always theta star.
It's the one that minimizes
the KL divergence,
am as long as I'm identified.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the
higher the curvature,
the higher the inverse of
the Fisher information?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
No, the higher
the Fisher information itself.
So the inverse is
going to be smaller.
So small variance is good.
So now what it
means, actually, if I
look at what is
the quadratic risk
of this guy,
asymptotically-- what
is asymptotic quadratic risk?
Well, it's 0 actually.
But if I assume that
this thing is true,
that this thing is
pretty much Gaussian,
if I look at the
quadratic risk, well, it's
the expectation of the
square of this thing.
And so it's going to scale
like the variance divided by n.
The bias goes to
0, just by this.
And then the quadratic
risk is going
to scale like one over Fisher
information divided by n.
So here, the-- I'm not
mentioning the constants.
There must be constants, because
everything is asymptotic.
So for each finite
n, I'm going to have
some constants that show up.
Everybody just got their mind
blown by this amazing theorem?
So I mean, if you think about
it, the MLE can be anything.
I'm sorry to say to
you, in many instances,
the MLE is just going to be
an average, which is just
going to be slightly annoying.
But there are some
cases where it's not.
And we have to resort
to this theorem
rather than actually resorting
to the central limit theorem
to prove this thing.
And more importantly, even
if this was an average,
you don't have to even
know how to compute
the covariance matrix--
sorry, the variance
of this thing
to plug it into the
central limit theorem.
I'm telling you, it's actually
given by the Fisher information
matrix.
So if it's an average,
between you and me,
you probably want to go the
central limit theorem route
if you want to prove
this kind of stuff.
But if it's not, then
that's your best shot.
But you have to check
those conditions.
I will give you for
granted the 0.5.
Ready?
Any questions?
We're going to wrap
up this chapter four.
So if you have questions,
that's the time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What was the
quadratic risk up there?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: You
mean the definition?
AUDIENCE: No, the--
what is was for this.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well,
you see the quadratic risk,
if I think of it as
being one dimensional,
the quadratic risk
is the expectation
of the square of the difference
between theta hat and theta
star.
So that means that if I think
of this as having a normal 0, 1,
that's basically computing
the expectation of the square
of this Gaussian divided by n.
I just divided by square
root of n on both sides.
So it's the expectation of
the square of this Gaussian.
The Gaussian is mean 0, so
the expectation of the square
is just a variance.
And so I'm left with 1 over
the Fisher information divided
by n.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So let's
move on to chapter four.
And this is the
method of moments.
So the method of moments is
actually maybe a bit older
than maximum likelihood.
And maximum likelihood is
dated, say, early 20th century,
I mean as a systematic
thing, because as I said,
many of those guys are
going to be averages.
So finding an average is
probably a little older.
The method of moments,
there's some really nice uses.
There's a paper by Pearson in
1904, I believe, or maybe 1894.
I don't know.
And this paper, he was
actually studying some species
of crab in an island,
and he was trying
to make some measurements.
That's how he came up with this
model of mixtures of Gaussians,
because there was actually
two different populations
in this populations of crab.
And the way he actually
fitted the parameters
was by doing the
method of moments,
except that since there
were a lot of parameters,
he actually had to basically
solve six equations with six
unknowns.
And that was a
complete nightmare.
And the guy did it by hand.
And we don't know how
he did it actually.
But that is pretty impressive.
So I want to start--
and this first part
is a little brutal.
But this is a Course 18 class,
and I do not want to give you--
So let's all agree that this
course might be slightly more
challenging than AP statistics.
And that means that it's
going to be challenging just
during class.
I'm not going to ask you about
the Weierstrass Approximation
Theorem during the exams.
But what I want is to give
you mathematical motivations
for what we're doing.
And I can promise
you that maybe you
will have a slightly higher body
temperature during the lecture,
but you will come out
smarter of this class.
And I'm trying to motivate to
you for using mathematical tool
and show you where interesting
mathematical things that you
might find dry elsewhere
actually work very beautifully
in the stats literature.
And one that we saw was using
Kullback-Leibler divergence out
of motivation for maximum
likelihood estimation,
for example.
So the Weierstrass
Approximation Theorem
is something that comes
from pure analysis.
So maybe-- I mean, it took
me a while before I saw that.
And essentially,
what it's telling you
is that if you look
at a function that
is continuous on
an interval a, b--
on a segment a, b--
then you can actually
approximate it
uniformly well by
polynomials as long
as you're willing
to take the degree
of this polynomials
large enough.
So the formal statement
is, for any epsilon,
there exists the d that depends
on epsilon in a1 to ad--
so if you insist on having an
accuracy which is 1/10,000,
maybe you're going to need a
polynomial of degree 100,000,
who knows.
It doesn't tell you
anything about this.
But it's telling you
that at least you
have only a finite
number of parameters
to approximate those
functions that typically
require an infinite number of
parameters to be described.
So that's actually quite nice.
And that's the basis
for many things
and many polynomial
methods typically.
And so here, it's
uniform, so there's
this max over x that shows up
that's actually nice as well.
That's Weierstrass
Approximation Theorem.
Why is that useful to us?
Well, in statistics, I
have a sample of X1 to Xn.
I have, say, a unified
statistical model.
I'm not always
going to remind you
that it's identified--
not unified-- identified
statistical model.
And I'm going to assume
that it has a density.
You could think of
it as having a PMF,
but think of it as having
a density for one second.
Now, what I want is to
find the distribution.
I want to find theta.
And finding theta,
since it's identified
as equivalent to
finding P theta, which
is equivalent to finding f
theta, and knowing a function
is the same--
knowing a density is the
same as knowing a density
against any test function h.
So that means that if I want
to make sure I know a density--
if I want to check if two
densities are the same,
all I have to do is to
compute their integral
against all bounded
continuous functions.
You already know
that it would be true
if I checked for
all functions h.
But since f is a
density, I can actually
look only at functions
h that are bounded,
say, between minus 1 and
1, and that are continuous.
That's enough.
Agreed?
Well, just trust me on this.
Yes, you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Why is this--
like, why shouldn't you
just say that [INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, I can do that.
I'm just finding
a characterization
that's going to be
useful for me later on.
I can find a bunch of them.
But here, this one is
going to be useful.
So all I need to say is that f
theta star integrated against
X, h of x-- so this
implies that f--
if theta is equal to f
theta star not everywhere,
but almost everywhere.
And that's only true if I
guarantee to you that f theta
and f theta stars are densities.
This is not true
for any function.
So now, that means that, well,
if I wanted to estimate theta
hat, all I would have to do is
to compute the average, right--
so this guy here, the integral--
let me clean up a bit my board.
So my goal is to find theta
such that, if I look at f theta
and now I integrate it
against h of x, then
this gives me the same
thing as if I were
to do it against f theta star.
And I want this for any h,
which is continuous and bounded.
So of course, I don't know
what this quantity is.
It depends on my
unknown theta star.
But I have theta from this.
And I'm going to do the usual--
the good old statistical
trick, which is,
well, this I can write as
the expectation with respect
to P theta star of h theta of x.
That's just the integral of
a function against something.
And so what I can do
is say, well, now I
don't know this guy.
But my good old
trick from the book
is replace expectations
by averages.
And what I get--
And that's approximately by
the law of large numbers.
So if I can actually find
a function f theta such
that when I integrate
it against h
it gives me pretty much the
average of the evaluations
of h over my data
points for all h,
then that should be
a good candidate.
The problem is that's a
lot of functions to try.
Even if we reduced that
from all possible functions
to bounded and
continuous ones, that's
still a pretty large
infinite number of them.
And so what we can do is to use
our Weierstrass Approximation
Theorem.
And it says, well, maybe I don't
need to test it against all h.
Maybe the polynomials
are enough for me.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to look only at functions
h that are of the
form sum of ak--
so h of x is sum of
ak X to the k-th for k
equals 0 to d-- only
polynomials of degree d.
So when I look at the
average of my h's, I'm
going to get a term
like the first one.
So the first one here, this guy,
becomes 1/n sum from i equal 1
to n sum from k equal 0
to d of ak Xi to the k-th.
That's just the average
of the values of h of Xi.
And now, what I need
to do is to check
that it's the same
thing when I integrate
h of this form as well.
I want this to hold for all
polynomials of degree d.
That's still a lot of them.
There's still an infinite
number of polynomials,
because there's an infinite
number of numbers a0 to ad
that describe those polynomials.
But since those guys
are polynomials,
it's actually enough for me
to look only at the terms
of the form X to the k-th--
no linear combination,
no nothing.
So actually, it's
enough to look only
at h of x, which is equal to X
to the k-th for k equal 0 to d.
And now, how many of
those guys are there?
Just d plus 1, 0 to d.
So that's actually a much
easier thing for me to solve.
Now, this quantity, which is the
integral of f theta against X
to the k-th-- so that the
expectation of X to the k-th
here--
it's called moment of order
k, or k-th moment of P theta.
That's a moment.
A moment is just the
expectation of the power.
The mean is which moment?
The first moment.
And variance is not
exactly the second moment.
It's the second moment minus
the first moment squared.
That's the variance.
It's E of X squared
minus E of X squared.
So those are things
that you already know.
And then you can go higher.
You can go to E of X
cube, E of X blah, blah.
Here, I say go to
E of X to the d-th.
Now, as you can see,
this is not something
you can really put
in action right now,
because the Weierstrass
Approximation Theorem does not
tell you what d should be.
Actually, we totally
lost track of the epsilon
I was even looking for.
I just said approximately
equal, approximately equal.
And so all this thing is
really just motivation.
But it's essentially
telling you that if you
go to d large
enough, technically
you should be able to identify
exactly your distribution up
to epsilon.
So I should be pretty good,
if I go to d large enough.
Now in practice, actually
there should be much
less than arbitrarily large d.
Typically, we are going
to need d which is 1 or 2.
So there are some limitations
to the Weierstrass Approximation
Theorem.
And there's a few.
The first one is
that it only works
for continuous functions, which
is not so much of a problem.
That can be fixed.
Well, we need bounded
continuous functions.
It works only on intervals.
That's annoying,
because we're going
to have random variables that
are defined beyond intervals.
So we need something that just
goes beyond the intervals.
And you can imagine that if
you let your functions be huge,
it's going to be
very hard for you
to have a polynomial
approximately [INAUDIBLE] well.
Things are going to start going
up and down at the boundary,
and it's going to be very hard.
And again, as I
said several times,
it doesn't tell us
what d should be.
And as statisticians, we're
looking for methods, not
like principles of existence
of a method that exists.
So if E is discrete,
I can actually
get a handle on this d.
If E is discrete and
actually finite--
I'm going to actually
look at a finite E,
meaning that I have a PMF on,
say, r possible values, x1
and xr.
My random variable,
capital X, can
take only r possible values.
Let's think of them as being
the integer numbers 1 to r.
That's the number of
success out of r trials
that I get, for example.
Binomial rp, that's exactly
something like this.
So now, clearly this
entire distribution
is defined by the PMF, which
gives me exactly r numbers.
So it can completely
describe this distribution
with r numbers.
The question is, do I have an
enormous amount of redundancy
if I try to describe this
distribution using moments?
It might be that I need--
say, r is equal to 10,
maybe I have only 10 numbers
to describe this thing,
but I actually need to compute
moments up to the order of 100
before I actually recover
entirely the distribution.
Maybe I need to go infinite.
Maybe the Weierstrass
Theorem is the only thing
that actually saves me here.
And I just cannot
recover it exactly.
I can go to epsilon if I'm
willing to go to higher
and higher polynomials.
Oh, by the way, in the
Weierstrass Approximation
Theorem, I can promise you
that as epsilon goes to 0,
d goes to infinity.
So now, really I don't even
have actually r parameters.
I have only r minus parameter,
because the last one--
because they sum up to 1.
So the last one I can
always get by doing
1 minus the sum of the
first r minus 1 first.
Agreed?
So each distribution
r numbers is described
by r minus 1 parameters.
The question is, can I
use only r minus moments
to describe this guy?
This is something called
Gaussian quadrature.
The Gaussian quadrature
tells you, yes, moments
are actually a good way to
reparametrize your distribution
in the sense that if
I give you the moments
or if I give you the
probability mass function,
I'm basically giving you
exactly the same information.
You can recover all the
probabilities from there.
So here, I'm going
to denote by--
I'm going to drop the
notation in theta.
I don't have theta.
Here, I'm talking about
any generic distribution.
And so I'm going to
call mk the k-th moment.
And I have a PMF, this
is really the sum for j
equals 1 to r of xj to
the k-th times p of xj.
And this is the PMF.
So that's my k-th moment.
So the k-th moment is a linear
combination of the numbers
that I am interested in.
So that's one equation.
And I have as many
equations as I'm actually
willing to look at moments.
So if I'm looking at 25
moments, I have 25 equations.
m1 equals blah with
this to the power of 1,
m2 equals blah with this to
the power of 2, et cetera.
And then I also
have the equation
that 1 is equal to the
sum of the p of xj.
That's just the
definition of PMF.
So this is r's.
They're ugly, but those are r's.
So now, this is a system
of linear equations in p,
and I can actually write it
in its canonical form, which
is of the form a
matrix of those guys
times my parameters of interest
is equal to a right hand side.
The right hand side
is the moments.
That means, if I
did you the moments,
can you come back and
find what the PMF,
because we know already
from probability
that the PMF is all I need
to know to fully describe
my distribution.
Given the moments,
that's unclear.
Now, here, I'm going to actually
take exactly r minus 1 moment
and this extra condition
that the sum of those guys
should be 1.
So that gives me r equations
based on r minus 1 moments.
And how many unknowns do I have?
Well, I have my r
unknown parameters
for the PMF, the r
values of the PMF.
Now, of course, this is
going to play a huge role
in whether the are many
p's that give me the same.
The goal is to find if there
are several p's that can give me
the same moments.
But if there's only one p that
can give me a set of moment,
that means that I have a
one-to-one correspondence
between PMF and moments.
And so if you give
me the moments,
I can just go back to the PMF.
Now, how do I go back?
Well, by inverting this matrix.
If I multiply this
matrix by its inverse,
I'm going to get the identity
times the vector of p's equal
the inverse of the
matrix times the m's.
So what we want to
do is to say that p
is equal to the inverse of this
big matrix times the moments
that you give me.
And if I can actually
talk about the inverse,
then I have basically
a one-to-one mapping
between the m's, the
moments, and the matrix.
So what I need to show is that
this matrix is invertible.
And we just decided
that the way to check
if a matrix is invertible is
by computing its determinant.
Who has computed a
determinant before?
Who was supposed to compute a
determinant at least than just
to say, no, you
know how to do it.
So you know how to
compute determinants.
And if you've seen any
determinant in class,
there's one that shows up in the
exercises that professors love.
And it's called the
Vandermonde determinant.
And it's the
determinant of a matrix
that have a very specific form.
It looks like-- so there's
basically only r parameters
to this r by r matrix.
The first row, or the
first column-- sometimes,
it's presented like that--
is this vector where each
entry is to the power of 1.
And the second one is each
entry is to the power of 2,
and to the power of 3, and
to the power 4, et cetera.
So that's exactly what we
have-- x1 to the first, x2
to the first, all the
way to xr to the first,
and then same thing
to the power of 2,
all the way to the last one.
And I also need to add
the row of all 1's, which
you can think of those guys are
to the power of 0, if you want.
So I should really
put it on top,
if I wanted to have
a nice ordering.
So that was the
matrix that I had.
And I'm not asking
you to check it.
You can prove that by
induction actually,
typically by doing the
usual let's eliminate
some rows and columns
type of tricks
that you do for matrices.
So you basically start
from the whole matrix.
And then you move onto a matrix
that has only one 1's and then
0's here.
And then you have Vandermonde
that's just slightly smaller.
And then you just iterate.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I feel like there's a
loss to either the supra index,
or the sub index should have
a k somewhere [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE] the one
I'm talking about?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, I know, but I
don't think the answer
to your question is yes.
So k is the general
index, right?
So there's no k. k does not
exist. k just is here for me
to tell me for k equals 1 to r.
So this is an r by r matrix.
And so there is no k there.
So if you wanted
the generic term,
if I wanted to put 1 in the
middle on the j-th row and k-th
column, that would be x--
so j-th row would be x
sub k to the power of j.
That would be the--
And so now, this is
basically the sum--
well, that should
not be strictly--
So that would be for j
and k between 1 and r.
So this is the
formula that get when
you try to expand this
Vandermonde determinant.
You have to do it only once when
you're a sophomore typically.
And then you can just go
on Wikipedia to do it.
That's what I did.
I actually made a
mistake copying it.
The first one should be 1
less than or equal to j.
And the last one should be
k less than or equal to r.
And now what you
have is the product
of the differences of xj and xk.
And for this thing
to be non-zero,
you need all the
terms to be non-zero.
And for all the
terms to be non-zero,
you need to have no xi, xj, and
no xj, xk that are identical.
If all those are
different numbers,
then this product is going
to be different from 0.
And those are different
numbers, because those
are r possible values that
your random verbal takes.
You're not going to
say that it takes two
with probability 1.5--
sorry, two with probability 0.5
and two with probability 0.25.
You're going to say it takes two
with probability 0.75 directly.
So those xj's are different.
These are the different values
that your random variable
can take.
Remember, xj, xk was just the
different values x1 to xr--
sorry-- was the different
values that your random variable
can take.
Nobody in their right mind
would write twice the same value
in this list.
So my Vandermonde is non-zero.
So I can invert it.
And I have a one-to-one
correspondence
between my entire PMF and
the first r minus 1's moments
to which I append the
number 1, which is really
the moment of order 0 again.
It's E of X to the
0-th, which is 1.
So good news, I only
need r minus 1 parameters
to describe r
minus 1 parameters.
And I can choose either
the values of my PMF.
Or I can choose the r
minus 1 first moments.
So the moments
tell me something.
Here, it tells me that if I
have a discrete distribution
with r possible
values, I only need
to compute r minus 1 moments.
So this is better than
Weierstrass Approximation
Theorem.
This tells me exactly how many
moments I need to consider.
And this is for
any distribution.
This is not a
distribution that's
parametrized by one
parameter, like the Poisson
or the binomial
or all this stuff.
This is for any distribution
under a finite number.
So hopefully, if I
reduce the family of PMFs
that I'm looking at to
a one-parameter family,
I'm actually going to need
to compute much less than r
minus 1 values.
But this is actually hopeful.
It tells you that
the method of moments
is going to work for
any distribution.
You just have to invert
a Vandermonde matrix.
So just the conclusion--
the statistical conclusion--
is that moments contain
important information
about the PMF and the PDF.
If we can estimate these
moments accurately,
we can solve for the
parameters of the distribution
and recover the distribution.
And in a parametric
setting, where
knowing P theta amounts
to knowing theta, which
is identifiability--
this is not innocuous--
it is often the case that
even less moments are needed.
After all, if theta is a
one dimensional parameter,
I have one parameter
to estimate.
Why would I go
and get 25 moments
to get this one parameter.
Typically, there
is actually-- we
will see that the
method of moments
just says if you have a
d dimensional parameter,
just compute d
moments, and that's it.
But this is only on
a case-by-case basis.
I mean, maybe your model will
totally screw up its parameters
and you actually
need to get them.
I mean, think about it, if the
function is parameterized just
by its 27th moment--
like, that's the only thing that
matters in this distribution,
I just describe the function,
it's just a density,
and the only thing that can
change from one distribution
to another is this 27th moment--
well, then you're going to
have to go get the 27th moment.
And that probably means that
your modeling step was actually
pretty bad.
So the rule of thumb, if theta
is in Rd, we need d moments.
So what is the
method of moments?
That's just a good old trick.
Replace the expectation
by averages.
That's the beauty.
The moments are expectations.
So let's just replace the
expectations by averages
and then do it with
the average version,
as if it was the true one.
So for example, I'm going to
talk about population moments,
when I'm computing them
with the true distribution,
and I'm going to talk about
them empirical moments, when
I talk about averages.
So those are the two
quantities that I have.
And now, what I hope
is that there is.
So this is basically--
everything is here.
That's where all the money is.
I'm going to assume there's
a function psi that maps
my parameters-- let's
say they're in Rd--
to the set of the
first d moments.
Well, what I want to do
is to come from this guy
back to theta.
So it better be that
this function is--
invertible.
I want this function
to be invertible.
In the Vandermonde
case, this function
with just a linear function--
multiply a matrix by theta.
Then inverting a linear function
is inverting the matrix.
Then this is the same thing.
So now what I'm
going to assume--
and that's key for this method
to work-- is that this theta--
so this function
psi is one to one.
There's only one theta that
gets only one set of moments.
And so if it's one to one, I
can talk about its inverse.
And so now, I'm going to
be able to define theta
as the inverse of the moments--
the reciprocal of the moments.
And so now, what I get is that
the moment estimator is just
the thing where rather than
taking the true guys in there,
I'm actually going to take the
empirical moments in there.
Before we go any
further, I'd like
to just go back and tell
you that this is not
completely free.
How well-behaved
your function psi
is going to play a huge role.
Can somebody tell me what
the typical distance--
if I have a sample
of size n, what
is the typical distance between
an average and the expectation?
What is the typical distance?
What is the order of magnitude
as a function of n between xn
bar and its expectation.
AUDIENCE: 1 over
square root of n.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 1
over square root n.
That's what the central limit
theorem tells us, right?
The central limit
theorem tells us
that those things are
basically a Gaussian, which
is of order of 1 divided
by its square of n.
And so basically, I
start with something
which is 1 over square root
of n away from the true thing.
Now, if my function psi inverse
is super steep like this--
that's psi inverse-- then
just small fluctuations, even
if they're of order
1 square root of n,
can translate into giant
fluctuations in the y-axis.
And that's going
to be controlled
by how steep psi inverse
is, which is the same
as saying how flat psi is--
how flat is psi.
So if you go back to
this Vandermonde inverse,
what it's telling you is that
if this inverse matrix blows up
this guy a lot--
so if I start from a small
fluctuation of this thing
and then they're
blowing up by applying
the inverse of
this matrix, things
are not going to go well.
Anybody knows what is the number
that I should be looking for?
So that's from, say,
numerical linear algebra
numerical methods.
When I have a system
of linear equations,
what is the actual
number I should
be looking at to
know how much I'm
blowing up the fluctuations?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Condition number?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: The
condition number, right.
So what's important here
is the condition number
of this matrix.
If the condition number
of this matrix is small,
then it's good.
It's not going to blow up much.
But if the condition
number is very large,
it's just going
to blow up a lot.
And the condition
number is the ratio
of the largest and the
smallest eigenvalues.
So you'll have to
know what it is.
But this is how all these
things get together.
So the numerical
stability translates
into statistical stability here.
And numerical
means just if I had
errors in measuring
the right hand side,
how much would they translate
into errors on the left hand
side.
So the error here is intrinsic
to statistical questions.
So that's my estimator,
provided that it exists.
And I said it's a one to
one, so it should exist,
if I assume that
psi is invertible.
So how good is this guy?
That's going to be
definitely our question--
how good is this thing.
And as I said, there's chances
that if psi is really steep,
then it should be
not very good--
if psi inverse is very steep,
it should not be very good,
which means that it's--
well, let's just
leave it to that.
So that means that
I should probably
see the derivative of
psi showing up somewhere.
If the derivative of psi
inverse, say, is very large,
then I should actually
have a larger variance
in my estimator.
So hopefully, just like we
had a theorem that told us
that the Fisher information
was key in the variance
of the maximum
likelihood estimator,
we should have a
theorem that tells us
that the derivative
of psi inverse
is going to have a key role
in the method of moments.
So let's do it.
So I'm going to talk
to you about matrices.
So now, I have--
So since I have to manipulate
d numbers at any given time,
I'm just going to concatenate
them into a vector.
So I'm going to call
capital M theta--
so that's basically
the population moment.
And I have M hat, which is
just m hat 1 to m hat d.
And that's my empirical moment.
And what's going
to play a role is
what is the variance-covariance
of the random vector.
So I have this vector 1--
do I have 1?
No, I don't have 1.
So that's a d
dimensional vector.
And here, I take the
successive powers.
Remember, that looks very much
like a column of my Vandermonde
matrix.
So now, I have
this random vector.
It's just the successive powers
of some random variable X.
And the variance-covariance
matrix is the expectation--
so sigma--
of theta.
The theta just means I'm
going to take expectations
with respect to theta.
That's the expectation
with respect
to theta of this
guy times this guy
transpose minus the same
thing but with the expectation
inside.
Why do I do X, X1.
I have X, X2, X3.
X, X2, Xd times the
expectation of X, X2, Xd.
Everybody sees what this is?
So this is a matrix where if I
look at the ij-th term of this
matrix--
or let's say, jk-th term,
so on row j and column k,
I have sigma jk of theta.
And it's simply the
expectation of X to the j
plus k-- well, Xj Xk minus
expectation of Xj expectation
of Xk.
So I can write this as m j plus
k of theta minus mj of theta
times mk of theta.
So that's my covariance matrix
of this particular vector
that I define.
And now, I'm going to
assume that psi inverse--
well, if I want to
talk about the slope
in an analytic fashion,
I have to assume
that psi is differentiable.
And I will talk
about the gradient
of psi, which is, if
it's one dimensional,
it's just the derivative.
And here, that's where
notation becomes annoying.
And I'm going to
actually just assume
that so now I have a vector.
But it's a vector
of functions and I
want to compute those functions
at a particular value.
And the value I'm
actually interested in
is at the m of theta parameter.
So psi inverse goes
from the set of moments
to the set of parameters.
So when I look at the
gradient of this guy,
it should be a function that
takes as inputs moments.
And where do I want this
function to be evaluated at?
At the true moment--
at the population moment vector.
Just like when I computed
my Fisher information,
I was computing it at
the true parameter.
So now, once they
compute this guy--
so now, why is this a
d by d gradient matrix?
So I have a gradient vector when
I have a function from rd to r.
This is the partial derivatives.
But now, I have a
function from rd to rd.
So I have to take the
derivative with respect
to the arrival coordinate
and the departure coordinate.
And so that's the
gradient matrix.
And now, I have the
following properties.
The first one is that
the law of large numbers
tells me that theta hat is a
weakly or strongly consistent
estimator.
So either I use the strong
law of large numbers
or the weak law
of large numbers,
and I get strong or
weak consistency.
So what does that mean?
Why is that true?
Well, because now so I
really have the function--
so what is my estimator?
Theta hat this psi inverse
of m hat 1 to m hat k.
Now, by the law
of large numbers,
let's look only at the weak one.
Law of large numbers tells
me that each of the mj hat
is going to converge
in probability as n
to infinity to the-- so
the empirical moments
converge to the
population moments.
That's what the good
old trick is using,
the fact that the
empirical moments
are close to the true
moments as n becomes larger.
And that's because, well,
just because the m hat j's
are averages, and the
law of large numbers
works for averages.
So now, plus if I look at my
continuous mapping theorem,
then I have that psi inverse
is continuously differentiable.
So it's definitely continuous.
And so what I have is
that psi inverse of m hat
1 m hat d converges to psi
inverse m1 to md, which
is equal to of theta star.
So that's theta star.
By definition, we assumed that
that was the unique one that
was actually doing this.
Again, this is a very
strong assumption.
I mean, it's basically saying,
if the method of moment works,
it works.
So the fact that psi
inverse one to one
is really the key to
making this guy work.
And then I also have a
central limit theorem.
And the central limit
theorem is basically
telling me that M hat
is converging to M even
in the multivariate sense.
So if I look at the vector of
M hat and the true vector of M,
then I actually make them go--
I look at the difference for
scale by square root of n.
It goes to some Gaussian.
And usually, we would see--
if it was one dimensional,
we would see the variance.
Then we see the
variance-covariance matrix.
Who has never seen the-- well,
nobody answers this question.
Who has already seen the
multivariate central limit
theorem?
Who was never seen the
multivariate central limit
theorem?
So the multivariate
central limit theorem
is basically just
the slight extension
of the univariate one.
It just says that
if I want to think--
so the univariate one would
tell me something like this--
and 0.
And then I would have basically
the variance of X to the j-th.
So that's what the central
limit theorem tells me.
This is an average.
So this is just for averages.
The central limit
theorem tells me this.
Just think of X to
the j-th as being y.
And that would be true.
Everybody agrees with me?
So now, this is
actually telling me
what's happening for all
these guys individually.
But what happens when those guys
start to correlate together?
I'd like to know if
they actually correlate
the same way asymptotically.
And so if I actually looked
at the covariance matrix
of this vector--
so now, I need to look at
a matrix which is d by d--
then would those univariate
central limit theorems
tell me--
so let me right like
this, double bar.
So that's just the
covariance matrix.
This notation, V double bar is
the variance-covariance matrix.
So what this thing tells
me-- so I know this thing
is a matrix, d by d.
Those univariate central
limit theorems only
give me information
about the diagonal terms.
But here, I have no idea where
the covariance matrix is.
This guy is telling me, for
example, that this thing is
like variance of X to the j-th.
But what if I want to
find off-diagonal elements
of this matrix?
Well, I need to use a
multivariate central limit
theorem.
And really what it's telling
me is that you can actually
replace this guy here--
so that goes in distribution
to some normal mean 0, again.
And now, what I
have is just sigma
of theta, which is just
the covariance matrix
of this vector X, X2, X3,
X4, all the way to Xd.
And that's it.
So that's a
multivariate Gaussian.
Who has never seen a
multivariate Gaussian?
Please, just go on
Wikipedia or something.
There's not much
to know about it.
But I don't have time to
redo probability here.
So we're going to
have to live with it.
Now, to be fair,
if your goal is not
to become a
statistical savant, we
will stick to
univariate questions
in the scope of
homework and exams.
So now, what was the
delta method telling me?
It was telling me that if I had
a central limit theorem that
told me that theta hat
was going to theta,
or square root of n
theta hat minus theta
was going to some
Gaussian, then I
could look at square root of Mg
of theta hat minus g of theta.
And this thing was also
going to a Gaussian.
But what it had to
be is the square
of the derivative of
g in the variance.
So the delta method,
it was just a way
to go from square
root of n theta
hat n minus theta goes to some
N, say 0, sigma squared, to--
so delta method was telling
me that this was square root
Ng of theta hat N
minus g of theta
was going in distribution
to N0 sigma squared
g prime squared of theta.
That was the delta method.
Now, here, we have a
function of those guys.
The central limit theorem,
even the multivariate one,
is only guaranteeing something
for me regarding the moments.
But now, I need to map the
moments back into some theta,
so I have a function
of the moments.
And there is something
called the multivariate delta
method, where derivatives
are replaced by gradients.
Like, they always are in
multivariate calculus.
And rather than multiplying,
since things do not compute,
rather than choosing which
side I want to put the square,
I'm actually just going to take
half of the square on one side
and the other half of the
square on the other side.
So the way you
should view this, you
should think of sigma
squared times g prime squared
as being g prime of
theta times sigma
squared times g prime of theta.
And now, this is
completely symmetric.
And the multivariate
delta method
is basically telling you that
you get the gradient here.
So you start from
something that's
like that over there, a sigma--
so that's my sigma squared,
think of sigma squared.
And then I premultiply by
the gradient and postmultiply
by the gradient.
The first one is transposed.
The second one is not.
But that's very
straightforward extension.
You don't even have
to understand it.
Just think of what would be
the natural generalization.
Here, by the way,
I wrote explicitly
what the gradient of a
multivariate function is.
So that's a function
that goes from Rd to Rk.
So now, the gradient
is a d by k matrix.
And so now, for this
guy, we can do it
for the method or moments.
And we can see that
basically we're
going to have this
scaling that depends
on the gradient of the
reciprocal of psi, which
is normal.
Because if psi is super steep,
if psi inverse is super steep,
then the gradient
is going to be huge,
which is going to translate
into having a huge variance
for the method of moments.
So this is actually the end.
I would like to encourage
you-- and we'll probably do it
on Thursday just to start.
But I encourage you do
it in one dimension,
so that you know how to
use the method of moments,
you know how to do
a bunch of things.
Do it in one dimension and see
how you can check those things.
So just as a quick comparison,
in terms of the quadratic risk,
the maximum likelihood
estimator is typically
more accurate than
the method of moments.
What is pretty
good to do is, when
you have a
non-concave likelihood
function, what
people like to do is
to start with the method of
moments as an initialization
and then run some algorithm
that optimizes locally
the likelihood starting
from this point,
because it's actually
likely to be closer.
And then the MLE is
going to improve it
a little bit by pushing the
likelihood a little better.
So of course, the
maximum likelihood
is sometimes intractable.
Whereas, computing
moments is fairly doable.
If the likelihood is
concave, as I said,
we can use optimization
algorithms,
such as interior-point
methods or gradient descent,
I guess, to maximize it.
And if the likelihood
is non-concave,
we only have local heuristics.
Risk And that's what I meant--
you have only local maxima.
And one trick you can do--
so your likelihood
looks like this,
and it might be the case that if
you have a lot of those peaks,
you basically have to start
your algorithm in each
of those peaks.
But the method of
moments can actually
start you in the right
peak, and then you
just move up by doing
some local algorithm
for maximum likelihood.
So that's not key.
But that's just if you want
to think about algorithmically
how I would end up doing this
and how can I combine the two.
So I'll see you on Thursday.
Thank you.